good morning John guess what's behind
this thing New York City and guess
what's behind this thing it's me I'm at
home again house in New York recession
just got a big new sponsor and we were
doing press tours talking to people
anyone who would listen to us about
science education and stuff you may have
noted that we've never ever done a
branded video here on blogger this this
is not one of those they don't know that
I'm making this video under sin for the
most part make stuff that you would
never buy unless you like own a power
plant or a fortune 500 company or
something so the advertisements that
we're doing together aren't about
getting people to buy their products
because that's not the problem they have
the problem they have is that they solve
big engineering problems and big science
problems and to do that they need
scientists and engineers and with not as
many people graduating with so-called
stem degrees more those people going to
work for big new companies that you've
heard of like Google and SpaceX and
Tesla they're a little worried and I
share their worry though for separate
reasons I don't hire engineer people for
the most part I'd hire humanities
people's like writers and video editors
and artists and stuff I'm concerned
because scientists and engineers solve a
lot of the big problems that we need to
solve like how do we get clean water to
more people and how do we continue to
power this amazing lifestyle that I get
to lead without destroying the world so
you know in this game to scishow is like
oh this makes sense actually we will do
that that STEM toolkit is a very
valuable one and one that is being
developed less often by people and what
I kept being asked by people on TV and
radio is that why why are a few blueing
this not on an expert on that I went
through school one time that's pretty
much all my data but as with those
things
my guess is it's a lot of different
reasons one reason is that I think it's
really hard and we just kind of
sugar-coated sometimes but it is hard
and there's a huge amount of information
to stick into your brain I think more
than that we're also told that there's a
certain type of person who becomes a
scientist or an engineer and they're
just good at it they're just good at
math and they're good at science they're
Engineering geniuses and that's a really
dangerous myth because everybody I know
who went through science or engineering
degree it was really hard for them it
was really hard for me nobody is born
being good at math I think some people
are born really liking that challenge
that's the thing that all of the
scientists I know haven't
like there's no other comment rate
amongst them their mothers and rock
climbers and punk rockers are in the
politics or sports as spend their
evenings on tumblr the only thing they
have in common is that passion for
solving hard problems and there are
certainly non science problems that need
to be solved as well that's why I hire
lots of artists and animators and video
editors and stuff I think often when we
tell people to get into STEM careers
it's not because it's interesting or
fascinating or cool it's because that's
the best way to get a good job so do
that if you don't do this terribly
difficult thing you will never get a
good job and I think that's a terrible
thing to do to a child who is like 15
years old they're in high school and
you're telling them okay to start
panicking now a decade before you will
be done learning all of these things
that's terrifying why can't we instead
treat this like every other big problem
and take it one step at a time being
driven not by the end goal but by you
know interests and fascinations along
the way and I want to say the most
interesting toolkit you can have is one
that includes both science in technology
engineering and liberal arts that's the
education I had and I'm so grateful for
it anyway this really is a career path
that's open to everyone so that's why I
was in New York I was doing things with
them and seeing lots of my friends and
hanging out cool people that was fun to
the other ties what we made together
just encouraging people to be interested
in fascinating science is running now
there's also a link below you can see it
on YouTube and if you think of yourself
Hank you were in New York City and you
did not tell me and I did not get to see
you that is so uncool I was very busy
but also I will be back in April with
Harry and the Potters Driftless Pony
Club Andrew Huang Rob Scallon
playing music all from like Chicago all
the way to New York there's like eight
stops you can check out more information
in the link in the description tour
because awesome
East Coast John I'll see you on Tuesday